an advantage of expressing the
asymptotic notations in terms of limits
is that a bunch of their properties then
become immediately obvious here's one if
F is little o of J or F is
asymptotically equal to J then in fact F
is Big O of J well we can reason about
this informally by saying that the first
one means that F is much less than J and
the second one means that F is about the
same as J and the final one means that F
is roughly less so being about the same
in definitely less is certainly this
implies roughly less but we can in fact
be entirely precise just using the
definitions because F equals o of G
means the limit of F over G is 0 and F
is asymptotically equal to G means that
the limit of F over G is 1 and the
definition of F equals Big O of G is
that the limit is finite and clearly if
it's 0 or 1 then it's finite um another
such property is that if F is much less
than G then G is not roughly less than F
more precisely if F is little o of G
then G is not Big O of F the left hand
side says that the limit of F over G is
0 but that implies that the limit of G
over F is 1 over 0 or infinity which
means it's not finite so G is not Big O
of F now the usual way that Big O is
defined in the literature doesn't
mention limits at all and in fact as I
said the definition really isn't a limit
it's a limb soup and let me show you the
standard definition and then he
explained why the limb soup captures it
and is needed so the definitely the
official definition of F is Big O of G
is that there's some constant multiplied
or see that you can amplify G by such
that once G is amplified by the factor C
then in fact F is less than or equal to
C times J but this doesn't may not hold
right at the beginning there's a certain
point and 0 after which it holds forever
let's try to illustrate this
complicated alternation of quantifiers
expression with a diagram that may make
it clearer so suppose that I want to
express the fact that F is Big O of G
where F is a green line so that green
line is the graph of f of X the function
and G in blue is shown and as a matter
of fact G of X is less than or equal to
f of X but nevertheless F is gonna be
little o Big O of G because if you
multiply G by a constant it becomes
where we're sort of shifting it up to it
be this constant times G it becomes this
purple curve and the purple curve it
gets to be above the green curve from a
certain point on that's n0 so by raising
up the blue curve G by an amount C to
get it to be this purple curve the
purple curve gets above F from a certain
point n0 on and that's why F is Big O of
G now of course multiplying the blue
curve G by a constant doesn't raise it
up a fixed amount it alters it but if we
imagine that our curve was a log scale
than in fact multiplying G by C is the
same as adding log C on a log scale so
the picture is actually accurate if the
vertical scale is logarithmic so using
this standard definition I can explain
why in the equivalent definition of
terms of limit I couldn't say limit I
needed to say limb soup here's what limb
soup does for us suppose I have a
function f that say less than or equal
to 2 G which means that surely F is Big
O of g according to the previous
definition because you amplify G by 2
and you get above F the problem is that
F of n over G event may have no limit so
I can't simply say that F is o of G
because the limit of F over G is finite
let's see what how that could happen
suppose that F is in fact equal to G
times a number that varies between 1 & 2
that's an example where um sine of n PI
over two varies between 0 1 and -1 and
you square it it becomes 0 or 1 and you
add 1 to it it becomes 1 or 2 so this is
an expression which as n grows
alternates between the values 1 and 2
and I'm multiplying G of n by this
constant that's either by this factor
this either 1 or 2 but the limit of f of
n over G of n does not exist it's
alternating between 1 & 2 on the other
hand the limb soup of F and of n over G
is 2 which is finite and therefore
according to the limb soup definition
indeed f is o of G now the technical
definition of limb soup is one that you
can read in the text or find in a
calculus book it's basically the largest
limit point of the fraction f of n over
G of n and if you don't know what a
limit point is it's stuff that we don't
need to go into but I did want you to
understand why formally we need Lim soap
in most cases the limit exists and we
can use the simpler limit definition
rather than the exists a constant such
that for every number and grade wrinkles
and 0 etc which is a more complicated
definition okay
let's collect a couple of more basic
facts about little o on that and Big O
that we're going to need namely that if
a is less than B it can be negative
numbers I don't care but real numbers if
a is less than B then X to the a is
little o of X to the B the proof follows
almost immediately from the definitions
because to prove that X to the a is
little o of X to the B we want to look
at the quotient of X to the a over X to
the B but of course the quotient of X to
the a over X to the B is equal to 1 over
X to the B minus a and since a is less
than B B minus a is positive so that
means that as X approaches infinity the
denominator is
to a positive power also goes to
infinity in therefore one over X to that
positive power goes to zero which is the
definition of X to the a being a little
all of X to the B another crucial fact
is that logarithms grow slower than
roots so if you think of Epsilon is like
a half or a third saying that the log of
X is less than or equal to the square
root it's less than equal to the cube
root it's less than or equal to 50 you
through it doesn't matter okay this is a
proof that just falls back on elementary
calculus and I guess I've highlighted it
because it's definitely worth
remembering logarithms grow slower than
roots
the proof is begins with the immediately
obvious remark that 1 over Y is less
than or equal to Y because they're equal
when y is greater equal to 1 1 over Y is
equal to Y when y is greater equal to 1
and as Y increases Y gets bigger and 1
over Y gets smaller so the inequality is
preserved that's easy
ok well that means that I can integrate
both sides starting at 1 so if I take
the integral of 1 over Y from 1 to Z
it's gonna be less than or equal to the
integral of Y from 1 to Z well integral
of 1 over Y is log Z and the integral of
Y is a 2 Z is Z squared over 2 so what
we get is this new inequality the log of
Z is less than or equal to Z squared
over 2 for Z greater equal to 1 so we're
on the way there we've got log of Z is
less than Z squared but not Z to any
epsilon power but we'll get that just
biting a smart substitution for Z so
that's the next step we have that log of
Z is less than or equal to Z squared
over 2 for any Z greater equal to 1
let's let Z be the square root of x to
the Delta where Delta is simply some
positive number so in that case what's
the log of Z well the log of the square
root of x to the Delta the square root
means it's 1/2 of log of X to the Delta
which is Delta log X so log of Z is
Delta log of X over 2 and of course Z's
squared is just X to the Delta sub Z
squared over two is X to the Delta over
two now I can just cancel the
denominators to and I get that log of X
and then transpose the Delta log of X is
less than or equal to X to the Delta
over Delta but Delta as long as Delta is
less than epsilon Delta X to the Delta
is going to be little lo of X to the
epsilon which means that X to the Delta
times a constant namely 1 over Delta is
also going to be a little low of X to
the epsilon and I've just figured out
that I've shown that log of X is little
o of X to the epsilon as required one
more crucial fact that I'm gonna not
prove but I'll state is that polynomials
grow slower than Exponential's this is
closely related to the fact that logs
grow slower than roots but in particular
if X is any kind of as C is any constant
and a is greater than 1 then X to the C
is little o of a to the X and there's a
bunch of ways to prove this using
l'hopital's rule or Maclaurin series and
I'll leave it to you to look up your
1801 calculus text to find a proof of
that fact